the clark county school district laying
the groundwork to get some students and
staff back into the classroom
kate houston joins us live in the
newsroom with some more clarification
from the district on how it plans to
accomplish this next step kate
yes today's superintendent dr jesus
jarrah said while there is no
set timeline or deadline if planning
goes smoothly there could be groups back
on campus by late february or early
march
last night the board of trustees
approved an agreement to eventually move
kindergarten through third grade into
a hybrid model principals will also be
able to bring small groups of students
who need extra support onto separate
campuses and that would be entirely
voluntary
dr jarrah says data from ccea shows a
majority of teachers
want to be back in class with students
he feels confident there will be enough
teachers to help the kids
now parents are weighing in trying to
decide what's best for their children
it's not safe to put a timeline on it
right now
so this was them you know like oh yeah
we want to do all these things
but we don't know when with six kids i
have six different mentalities
six different needs i have you know from
extremely
extremely smart extremely extremely
chatty too
quiet i mean all kinds of of needs there
and i feel that they need to be in
school in order to get kids back in the
classroom
principals will need to submit their
plan to a regional superintendent for
approval
dr jara says they are working together
to ensure there is equity for students
across the entire district another
factor in this decision is the high
covet 19 positivity rate in the state
dr jarrah says he is working with the
county to hopefully start vaccinating
teachers
by the end of this month back to you all
right thanks kate now we did ask on
twitter do you understand ccsd's plan
toward reopening schools
84 percent of you who waited said nope
16 said yes well we understand this
process is confusing
and there are no clear-cut answers at
this point but we promise you
eight news now is constantly working to
find answers for all of you